hi there steve kaufman here today and
today i'm going to talk about my new
approach to learning three languages
uh i was at the polyglot conference in
japan
oh and by the way if you enjoy my videos
please subscribe give me a thumbs up
apparently these are
good for my readings which apparently is
a good thing to push for but you're
entirely free to do whatever you want
uh of course
so
polyglot there are a lot of people there
who speak five four five six seven
languages uh i decided a while ago that
i wanted to work on the three languages
that i'm now sort of focused on arabic
persian and turkish
i started out doing three months on one
three months on the other three months
on the third one then back to the first
one the problem with that is that i find
that i slip a bit too much so i want to
try to balance all three of them as i
learn all three of them
so learning three languages at the same
time how do we do it
now luca lampariello has put out a video
and a
blog post on the subject
you can google for it uh elisa police
both of them are well-known polyglots
she has an approach to learning three
languages simultaneously you can search
for her
i just don't as i'm doing this video i
just don't have any
links that i can give you but it's easy
enough to google um
now my approach i'm not doing it the way
they are doing i think luca is learning
danish
greek and
hungarian
and the danish is new to him
although he knows swedish
uh
greek he's been out for two years in
hungarian he's been at for five years
now
i recognize that when we say we've been
doing a language for two or three or
five years that doesn't mean we've been
doing it 100
probably he's been doing other languages
there as well i've been working on
korean off and on for many years and i'm
still not satisfied with my level in
korean however
my focus right now is arabic persian and
turkish so
i thought to myself how do i control how
much time i spend on each if i want to
do a little bit of each every day
so i was thinking of my electric
toothbrush now if i brush my teeth
manually
then there's no control over how much
time i spend brushing my teeth and i
probably don't brush them long enough
not to mention the fact that probably
i'm not doing as much good to my gums
as is the case with this
sonic
toothbrush from phillips the sonic
toothbrush from phillips
goes for two minutes so there is i don't
have to think about it i just continue
cleaning my teeth until i hit two
minutes and then i stop so that that's
sort of an automatic control of how long
i brush my teeth i then floss
but that's easy enough to do because i
have only so many teeth so once i finish
flossing i'm done
how does that apply to languages well
up until now with my three languages
here and of course i bought books on
turkish on arabic i also have the asimil
on farsi or persian
and i've kind of been doing i've been a
bit of a nomad i do whatever i want when
i feel like listening i listen when i
feel like reviewing something in the
book i do so and i spend an awful lot of
time going over and over
our mini stories and all of that i think
has been good has made me kind of
familiar with those three languages with
some of the essential you know
structures of the language some key
vocabulary but i feel now that i'm in a
bit of a rut i've got to get beyond the
many stories beyond reviewing you know
sort of simple dialogue simple grammar
points for the nth time and still
forgetting them so what i've decided to
do and i'm going to stick to it and i
recommend you do the same
i have
changed my goal at link
i have set it at a hundred links a day
so every day in each language i'm going
to create a hundred links that another
in other words i'm going to force myself
into
new content where there are enough
unknown words that in fact i can easily
create a hundred new links so i'm going
to wean myself away from the many
stories and content where i'm trying to
read it for the nth time to try to
remember the words that i keep
forgetting and listening for the nth
time to try to remember what i forgot
already i'm just going to assume i've
done enough of that
now if i move forward any words or
structures that are important enough
will show up again so as long as i
create my 100 links a day and i maintain
that streak and link tracks that tracks
your streak
if i continue doing that 100 in persian
100 in arabic and a hundred
in turkish
i will be necessarily reading a lot
because it forces me to read in between
the
links that i create i'm not just going
to go through and link a bunch of stuff
i'm going to read the text try to make
sense of it
and
and obviously i'm not going to i'm going
to there's going to be text that i
understand imperfectly some of the
arabic texts i'm doing
are transcripts from these podcasts on
uh franz vadcat and the transcripts are
automatic so they make mistakes so the
whole thing is a little fuzzy but i
don't mind i'm reading through them i'm
reviewing words that i've previously
saved
and every day i'm creating a hundred
links
the listening part is not difficult
because essentially i only listen when
i'm doing something else so i listen
when i'm exercising i listen when i'm in
the car i listen when i'm doing the
dishes so i will get in enough
um listening
i am going to try like these uh podcasts
on fonts.cat one of the reasons why i
transcribed them is so that i can create
a lesson in link so that i can listen
from link so that it automatically
tracks tracks how many minutes or hours
of listening i'm doing even though it's
not ideal because the transcripts are
not as accurate as they could be
i wish there were
podcasts and one great thing is if i'm
following current events i'm familiar
with the context so if they're talking
about the turkish incursion into syria
or
riots in iraq or whatever they're
talking about
i know that background the context so
it's easier for me to follow and so i
like
news current events podcasts that kind
of thing ideally audio with transcript
that's what i'm trying to create because
it's i then stay in a familiar context
easier to understand
so that's essentially what i'm going to
do
um
i'm not going to interact with tutors
for the next nine months
nine months they used to be three months
on language a then b then c i'm gonna go
nine months mixing them every day a
hundred links a day
which necessarily forces me to read if
i listen to something and i want to go
over it again even though i've
you know
cleaned out all the blue
new words i i still will manually
indicate that i've read that again so
that i at least keep track of my reading
but i'm not going to be driven by my
reading i want to simplify this thing i
am driven by simply by the desire to
create links to convert blue new words
to
either to ignore them because they're
you know proper names
or to convert them into yellow words
links that in time i will learn
um
you know if i do this at a 100 links a
day and let's say there's 270 let's say
250 days
times 100 and what's that 25 000
links that i will create
um that's a lot
i believe the math is right there 250
times 100
and
based on my experience in other
languages like greek and
korean and stuff
that will probably bring my known words
total up over ten thousand
uh i'm already at eight thousand in
turkish and arabic and i think i have
twenty thousand links created in each of
those languages so it can take me up to
forty five thousand links created which
should bring my known words total up to
15 or 20 thousand so i think that'll
improve my vocabulary my familiarity
with the language i won't be interacting
with the tutor because
part of the reason for interacting with
a tutor part of the reason for spending
so much time on the many stories is to
improve my ability to say something but
i always feel i'm doing that at the
expense of acquiring more vocabulary and
getting used to more of the language in
different contexts so
no tutor and that minimizes the
opportunity to confuse the languages
because i'm just going to be listening
and reading and then at the end of nine
months i'm going to pick up again with
my tutors and we'll see
to what extent i have improved so this
is an experiment maybe i'll be just as
bad as speaking then as i am right now
but i will have a larger vocabulary and
that is the program that i'm going to be
on learning three languages every day by
making sure that every day
i create 100 links which means
i
look up 100 new words that i didn't know
before and they enter my database of
words that i'm trying to learn and all
the rest of it the reading the listening
will simply fall into place and if i'm
curious about a point of grammar i may
look it up but i'm not going to try to
remember stuff that's in these books
there you have it that's my new approach
i look forward to your comments bye for
now
[Music]
you